since its release on Tuesday Prince Harry's
revealing and controversial Memoir has jumped
to the top of several bestseller lists spare has
been making headlines as the 38-year-old former
senior member of the British royal family Bears
all the latest interview with Harry airs tonight
on CBS and this morning Harry himself reads
excerpts from his book and provides more of
the surprising Recollections that have garnered
the world's attention I love my father I love
my brother I love my family I always do nothing
of what I've done in this book or otherwise has
ever been to any intention to harm them or hurt
them in his debut Memoir Prince Harry shares
a glimpse into his most private relationships
including with his brother Prince William and
father King Charles your two criticism of your dad
really I would say summarizing kind of intimacy
and communication problems he's not there for
you as frequently or in quite the way you want
he'd always given an air of being not quite ready
for Parenthood the responsibilities the patience
the time even he though a proud man would have
admitted as much but single Parenthood power was
never made for that to be fair he tried no topic
seems off limits as he reads a vivid description
of a physical altercation between he and Prince
William it all happened so fast so very fast
he grabbed me by the collar ripping my
necklace and he knocked me to the floor
I landed on the dog's ball which cracked under my
back the pieces cutting into me I lay there for a
moment dazed and got to my feet and told him to
get out come on hit me you'll feel better if you
hit me do what come on we always used to fight
you'll feel better if you hit me no only you'll
feel better if I hit you please just leave he
left the kitchen but he didn't leave not caught
he was in the sitting room I could tell I stayed
in the kitchen two minutes passed two long minutes
he came back looking regretful and apologized
he walked to the front door this time I followed
before leaving he turned and called back
you don't need to tell Meg about this
you mean that you attacked me I didn't attack
you Harold fine I won't tell her his transparency
shows a side of the royal family many have not
seen they're going to be sitting there reeling
at this level of personal disclosure aren't they
and that and that will make some people angry
though we have to be honest about that of course
some people will say you have railed against
invasions of your privacy all your life but they
the accusation will be here are you invading the
privacy of your most nearest and dearest without
permission that'll be the accusation that'll
be the accusation from the people that don't
understand or haven't or don't want to believe
that my family have been briefing the press
solidly for well over a decade so I'm sorry
that me owning my story and being able to tell my
own story is upsetting to some people but I have
to rely on the truth despite it all Prince Harry
remains hopeful for reconciliation I think there's
probably a lot of people who after watching the
documentary and reading the book will go how could
you ever forgive your family for what they've done
people have already said that to me and I said
forgiveness is 100 a possibility because I would
like to get my father back I would like to have
my brother back at the moment I don't recognize
them as much as they probably don't recognize me
and you can see all of the Prince Harry interview
tonight at 8 7 Central right here on CBS where you
can stream it on Paramount plus beginning tomorrow
I I I I I I don't even know what to say when you
sit and you watch him explain the things that
he explains he lived through or claims to have
lived through he has a very believable air about
him it just I take it in with everything else we
know the crown I mean even the fictionalized
version of what we watch and what we see it
plays into his narrative it's been fascinating
to watch all of it I can't get enough I admit it
I'll be watching yeah and this is
him reading from the book yeah yeah